[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
SARAH HEWETT: All right.
We can probably get started.
So good afternoon.
And today, we are going to start
talking about the final lab
that we are going to
talk about in the lecture
and the final lab
that you haven't
heard about yet for the course,
which is the catalase lab.
And some of you guys
started that yesterday.
And some of you
will start it today.
And then the rest of you will
have to wait a little bit.
But the catalase lab is our
biochemistry type lab that we
were doing in 5.310.
And catalase is an enzyme if
you couldn't tell by the name.
A lot of enzyme names--
you guys are familiar from your
biology classes-- end in ase.
So catalase is an enzyme.
And enzymes are proteins-- just
a review of your general bio--
that carry out specific
chemical reactions.
And they're produced by
different living organisms.
They work in the cells to do a
very wide range of chemistry.
And there are many different
graphical representations,
weird pictures that you can
find on the internet that
try to depict what an enzyme
actually does in cartoon form.
And so here are a couple
of examples of that.
So you have your enzyme
and then you have
what's called your substrate.
And so that is the thing that
the enzyme is doing chemistry
on.
The substrate comes in.
It interacts with your enzyme
to form an enzyme substrate
complex.
Then the chemistry happens.
And then the enzyme
releases the product.
So sometimes the products will
be rearranging the substrate.
Sometimes it will be
taking two substrates
and joining them together.
And sometimes it will
be taking one substrate
and breaking it apart.
So there's a bunch of
different reactions
that can happen in
different enzymes.
Similar thing-- if you
want to look at your enzyme
as a little Pacman kind of guy.
You form the enzyme
substrate complex.
You form your products.
And then they break apart.
So that's the general
idea of how enzymes
works in a very quick nutshell.
So our specific
enzyme is catalase.
And here are a couple of
pictures of catalase or artist
renditions of catalase.
So this is a space
filling model of what
it would look like if all of
the atoms were kind of 3D balls.
So you can see it has four
different subdomains here.
And then these darker
parts in the middle
with the little green dot,
those are your heme center,
so these are iron
molecules and that's
where the chemistry happens.
So these are the active
sites of the catalase.
And you can also-- you may have
seen in other courses proteins
represented like this,
which has a little bit more
of the features of their
secondary and tertiary
structure.
So you can see the alpha
helices and beta sheets.
And we're going to talk
more about the structure
of the active site and
how the chemistry happens
and what all of those
squiggles mean next week
when we talk about catalase.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SARAH HEWETT: Yes.
Or wait.
Each sub-domain has
one active site.
So it has one heme in
each of the four parts.
And we'll talk more
about that next week
when we go a little bit deeper
into the structure of catalase
and how it works.
And then the other
important thing
you need to know about catalase
is it's a large molecule.
Proteins generally are.
There are polypeptides--
lots and lots of amino acids.
And so its weight
is 240 kilodaltons.
And a kilodalton is
1,000 mass units.
So it's 240,000 grams per mole.
And you'll need that
for some calculations
that you'll do in the
second half of the lab.
And we'll go over that
again in the next lecture.
But to give you an
idea of the size
of that thing and the molar
mass, it is very large.
Why do we need catalase?
So there are many
redox reactions
that are happening in your body
where you do electron transfer
reactions and you oxidize
or reduce different things
in your metabolism.
And so electrons are
transferred around cells.
You may have heard of the
molecule NADPH or NADH.
Those transfer electrons
between different molecules
in your cells and
help with metabolism.
And while these electrons
are being transferred around,
you also know that
we breathe oxygen
and we need oxygen
to do-- to perform
many of our life processes.
So you have a lot of oxygen
in your body as well.
And during a lot of
these metabolic processes
you can get electrons that
are transferred to oxygen.
So if we have our oxygen
and it gains an electron,
we have what is
called superoxide.
So now this has
a negative charge
and an unpaired electron.
And so it is a
superoxide radical.
And what do we know
about radicals?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SARAH HEWETT: They
would like to be stable.
So they are not
stable because they
have this unpaired electrons.
So they will either
give up this electron
or try to take an electron
from something else
in order to have
their electron be--
or not be unpaired anymore.
So these are very
reactive in the body.
And this is actually a problem.
And we don't want
this in our cells
because it is so reactive.
So there is another enzyme
called superoxide dismutase
that breaks this apart
into elemental oxygen
and oddly enough
hydrogen peroxide.
But it turns out that
hydrogen peroxide
in high enough concentrations
is also toxic to your cells.
And hydrogen peroxide can
form hydroxy radicals,
which are also very
damaging to your cells.
There's a couple of reactions
that hydrogen peroxide
can do in the body.
So the first is if you
have hydrogen peroxide
and then you have some of
this superoxide around--
so it's a radical anion there.
You can make oxygen,
hydroxide ions, which are OK,
and then hydroxy radicals.
So then you form more radicals
and those can go and damage
your DNA, your proteins,
the different fatty acids
in your body, and cause
all kinds of problems.
Another thing that can happen
is if there's just hydrogen
peroxide around and it picks up
an electron, it can form water
and another hydroxyl radical.
So these are the
reactions that we do not
want to happen in our body
because it forms these--
it just keeps propagating.
And then when radicals react
with other things that have all
paired electrons, it
generates more radicals
and you propagate
the radical formation
throughout your cell it
causes a lot of damage.
So we need a way to
get rid of the hydrogen
peroxide in our body and
that is what catalase is for.
And all organisms have catalase.
You can extract it out of
humans, all types of mammals,
even plants have it.
Cells do not want
hydrogen peroxide in them.
So there are different
forms of catalase
that you can get from any
organism-- bacteria, all
the things.
The catalase that we're
going to be using in the lab
was extracted from cows.
So just a fun fact.
And when we're
talking about enzymes,
the reason that enzymes are
so good and so efficient
at their jobs is because they
catalyze chemical reactions.
And a lot of you are
chemical engineers,
so you probably know
about catalysis.
So what does it mean for
something to be a catalyst?
Anyone?
Please give me a quick
catalyst definition.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] reaction.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
It speeds up a
chemical reaction.
And it's not used up
during the process.
So if we look at our
energy reaction diagram,
if you have energy on this
side and then reaction
progress on this
axis, you can say
that you have reactants that
are starting at a certain energy
level.
And then you have
some energy that you
have to put into the
reaction to get it to go.
And then in a lot of cases, if
your reaction is exothermic,
your products maybe at
a lower energy level.
So it'll release energy overall.
But in order to get
the reaction to go
you have to put energy in.
So this part of the curve is
our delta H of our reaction.
So it would be the
energy released
if it's exothermic, which in
this case this reaction is.
But no matter what you
need to put in some energy
to get the reaction
to go and this
is called the activation energy.
Occasionally
abbreviated E sub a.
So this is what
we care about when
we're talking about
reaction kinetics
and what a catalyst does.
So a catalyst functions and
it makes the reaction faster
by lowering this energy barrier.
So if the yellow line is the
reaction without a catalyst,
then with a catalyst
it will be smaller.
And the products
and the reactants
will have the same total
energy, but the energy
you need to put in to
get the reaction to go
is going to be less.
And so the reaction
can go faster
and it can go in
milder conditions.
And we can talk
about how enzymes
work to lower this
activation energy.
So does anybody know
what methods enzymes
use to lower the activation
energy of a reaction?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Proximity?
Just getting the
reactants together?
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
Proximity.
So it gets the reactants
close together.
If you have your
reactants in a beaker
and they're all
floating around, they
have to find each other
before they can react.
And so if you have
an enzyme that
has a specifically
designed active site
to hold these two
molecules close together,
then they will react.
What else?
AUDIENCE: It can stabilize
a transition state?
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
It can stabilize a
transition state.
And how does it do that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
So it bonds to the
substrate and it
can have either electrostatic
or even sometimes covalent
interactions.
And it stabilizes
the transition state.
And part of the way
that it does that is it
holds the molecules in the right
orientation for them to react.
So even if you
have two molecules,
if they're supposed to
interact like this to react
and they're in a beaker
and they hit on this side
or upside down, the
reaction will not happen.
So we can stabilize
transition states.
Your transition state
and put molecules
in the correct orientation.
Anything else?
There is one more
thing that they can do.
OK.
What's your idea?
AUDIENCE: If they raise the
temperature, it will increase--
collisions could increase.
SARAH HEWETT: So increasing
the temperature of a reaction
will get it to go faster.
Right?
But that's just
because then you will
have more molecules that
have the necessary activation
energy.
So you're not necessarily
lowering the activation energy
that the reaction needs.
But the last thing
that they can do
is they can provide
alternate reaction pathways.
So sometimes you may
think that this will just
be a one-step reaction.
If you had an enzyme,
occasionally it'll
look like this.
It might provide an extra
intermediate in there
that helps to lower
the overall energy.
And so that's
another way that it
can lower this overall
activation energy
is by providing an
alternate mechanism
other than maybe just two
molecules reacting together.
There might be a
third intermediate
that helps actually
lower the overall energy.
So those are possible ways
that the enzymes can work
to lower the activation energy.
And so our goals for
the catalase lab are--
well, there are a few
goals that we have.
But our goals for
days one and two
are to determine the
activation energy of hydrogen--
the decomposition of hydrogen
peroxide as catalyzed
by the catalase enzyme.
So we're going to
try and figure out
what the activation energy
is after it's already
been catalyzed.
And in order to do
this, we are going
to need to first determine
the order of the reaction
with respect to
hydrogen peroxide
and be able to write a rate law.
That'll help us
characterize the kinetics.
So in day one of
this lab, you're
going to do that first part.
And you're going to figure out
what the order of the reaction
is.
And in order to have
that make any sense
we need to talk about kinetics
and how we discuss kinetics
in a chemical sense.
So kinetics deals with the
speed of chemical reactions.
And if we use everybody's
favorite generic reaction
a plus b goes to c plus d.
You can write the rate of this
reaction-- you can express it
in a number of ways.
So the first way is
to think of the rate
of the reaction as the change
in the reactants over time--
so a and b.
And it has a negative
sign because you
are losing the reactants.
Hopefully they're going away
as the reaction progresses.
And it is equal to the
rate of the appearance
of c and the appearance of d.
So these do not
have negative signs
because you are
making your product.
So that is one way to express
the rate of the reaction.
And when you do it this way,
you need to account for the fact
that there are
different molar ratios.
So the reactants
and the products
will disappear in form
at different rates
depending on how many of them
you need in the reaction.
So to account for that, we
multiply by the reciprocal
of this coefficient.
We can also write
a generic rate law
like this where your rate
equals your rate constant, which
you can calculate
and determine in lab
and is dependent
on the temperature
times the concentration
of your reactants raised
to a power and
your concentration
of your other reactants
raised to a different power.
And you can also write
an integrated rate law,
which you may have seen before.
So integrated rate laws deal
with one reactant at a time.
And so if we look at a, we
can say-- we can write--
if there's only a we can write
the rate of a equals the rate
constant times a.
Or we can say that the rate
is equal to the disappearance
of a overtime.
And you can take the
derivative of this.
So if we move everything
over, rearrange it--
So if we integrate
both sides of this--
if we integrate this side from
your initial concentration
to your concentration
at some temperature
and this side from t
equals 0 to some time t,
then if you do that math out you
will get the natural log of--
this is your integrated rate law
if your exponent here equals 1.
So obviously, that will change
if you have different exponents
here.
And then when you
do your integration
you will get different values.
But this is a way to
relate the concentration
at your initial concentration
to a concentration
at a final temperature
or a final time.
So that's one thing
that you've probably
seen before in some of your
other chemistry classes.
And we can also talk about--
well, we'll talk about
that in a second.
You may also have seen in some
of your other classes enzyme
kinetics or heard of
Michaelis-Menten kinetics.
And the Michaelis-Menten
model of enzyme kinetics
says that if you have
an enzyme and you
have a bunch of substrate,
the reaction can only
go as fast as there is
when there's only one
substrate in each enzyme.
So if all of the active
sites are full of substrate,
then that is as fast
as the reaction can go.
And it will proceed
at a steady state.
So you can make
graphs of the reaction
rate versus how much
concentration of substrate
you have.
And you can get this
Michaelis-Menten constant here,
which is a measure of
how much the enzyme--
what its affinity is for
the substrate essentially.
So does the enzyme need a
whole bunch of substrate
before it'll start
going quickly?
Or can it go quickly
and efficiently
with just a tiny
concentration of substrate?
So we're not going
to worry so much
about those parameters
for our lab right now.
But this is something
you may have seen.
And one of the assumptions of
the Michaelis-Menten kinetics,
which is actually kind
of important to us
is that you have your
enzyme and your substrate.
They make the enzyme
substrate complex.
And then they go to
enzyme and product.
And they don't go in
the reverse reaction.
So that's kind of
important to us
that if we are trying to measure
the rates of our reactions,
that we don't have to contend
with the reactions being
catalyzed in reverse.
All right.
So now we can take a
little bit of a closer look
at the rate law for just a
normal chemical reaction.
And pretty much the
most important thing
you want to know about this
is that the units of the rate
are always moles per
liter per second.
So whenever you are trying
to calculate a rate constant,
you want your units to line up.
So if your rate--
if we want this in
molarity per second--
if your rate equals--
let's say these are both
equal to 1 just for now.
Then what are our
units over here?
M and M. So what are the
units of k have to be?
So that's how you can figure
out what the units of your rate
constant are because
it always needs
to multiply with your
concentrations and your k
to equal moles per
liter per second.
And that is going to be
the units of our rate
that we care about in
our kinetic equations.
The rate constant is different
at different temperatures.
So if you change the
temperature of the reaction,
then your rate
constant will change
and you'll have
to remeasure that.
And x and y are values
that need to be determined.
They may be the same as little
a and little b but not always.
So the kinetics
of a reaction are
determined if it's a
multi-step reaction
if their reaction mechanism
has more than one part in it.
They may not all be reflected in
this overall chemical equation.
You may not see
them, but the rate
is going to be dependent
on your slowest step.
And that slowest
step is what is going
to determine your rate law.
And it may not always match
your overall reaction equation.
So be careful when you are
determining these things.
You can't always just
assume that it is
from the little a and little b.
So how are we going to determine
the order for our reaction?
And this is what are
going to do on day one.
We will use our
rate law expression
to determine the
order of the reaction.
So you're going to--
according to our rate law here.
It's the only reactant
that we have in this case
is hydrogen
peroxide, and we need
to determine what its order is.
So if we change the
concentration of the peroxide,
we should change the rate, yes?
So if we do a bunch of
reactions with a bunch
of different
concentrations of peroxide,
we can measure the
rates, and then
use the relationship
between those two things
to figure out our
concentration of--
or our order of the reaction.
So the way that you're
going to do this in lab
is you will have a
series of solutions,
and these are your solutions.
You'll have a stock
hydrogen peroxide solution
that you're going to make up.
It's going to be about
4% hydrogen peroxide.
You'll use a phosphate buffer.
Why do we need to use a
buffer for this reaction?
What's a buffer, I guess
is the first question?
AUDIENCE: It helps the
solution from changing PH2.
SARAH HEWETT: Perfect.
So a buffer helps the solution,
it prevents a solution
from changing PH.
So you can make a buffer
out of certain PH,
and then if acid or
base gets added to it,
it resists the change in PH.
It keeps the constant.
Why is that important
for our reaction?
AUDIENCE: Maybe [INAUDIBLE].
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
So enzymes are most
functional at a set PH.
So your PH of your
body is around 7,
so we want to keep
the PH of our reaction
somewhere around our
physiological PH,
so our buffer is going to
be set to PH 6.8, which
is going to help make
sure that the enzyme is
in its active state.
It is not denatured.
If you change the
PH too much, you'll
change the protonation
state of the different parts
of the protein, and
it can fall apart.
So we want to make
sure that this
is happening at the correct PH.
We'll add some
enzyme, and then we
will measure the
rate of the reaction.
And we're going to do that
using this apparatus right here.
So you'll have one of these.
You'll have a water
bath, so that we can
keep the temperature constant.
So you'll just fill this
with room temperature water,
and then you can
monitor the temperature
throughout your reaction to make
sure that it does not change.
And then this is
your reaction vessel
here, your pressure tube,
because you will be putting
all of your solutions in here.
You will add your
peroxide and your buffer,
and then you will
put this cap on.
And this Teflon cap here,
it's important to note,
has an O-ring on the bottom.
And so you want to
make sure when you're
doing this reaction
that you're O-ring
is in there, because
that'll make a good seal,
so you won't have
your products escaping
because our product is a gas.
So you'll screw this on.
And then there's a
hole in the top here.
You can inject your
enzyme really fast.
You're going be doing
this in partners.
Somebody can inject
the enzyme really fast.
And then you want to
connect your pressure tube.
And this tube is connected
to a pressure sensor.
And this pressure
sensor will be connected
to your computer, which
is why you need to bring
a laptop for the catalase lab.
And we will give you
the Logger Pro software.
And it will send the data
directly to your laptop.
And it'll plot it for you.
And you'll get a
curve that, hopefully,
looks something like this.
And we will measure the pressure
of oxygen formed in kilopascals
versus time in seconds.
And it'll graph
this thing for you.
And the slope of
the graph is going
to be your rate of
kilopascals per second.
And we want to take the rate
at this first part of the graph
where it is linear,
and why do we
want to take the rate at the
beginning of our reaction?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Reaction rate
is dependent on amount
of reactants?
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
So the reaction rate is
dependent on the amount
of reactants, and the--
so the rate of this reaction
obviously changes over time,
and we set up our
reactions so that we know
the concentration of peroxide.
And the only time
in this reaction
that we're theoretically
going to know
the concentration of
peroxide is at the beginning,
before some of it has
reacted and the rate changes.
So we want to measure
the initial rate so
that we know our concentration,
and that we get a--
we have a consistent
place to take our data
from on each measurement.
So once we have done all of
these different reactions--
you'll do all four of them--
all of the same procedure
in the same tube-- you'll
make five different graphs.
You'll have this.
Then how do we analyze this
data and get information
about the order out of it?
So here we are going to have
to do a little bit of math.
So here are some of the
steps of the data analysis.
The first thing that
you're going to have to do
is calculate the concentration
of the peroxide that you used.
And we are going to give you 30%
hydrogen peroxide, which is--
its volume per volume-- so
there's 30 milliliters of H2O2,
and 70 millimeters of water.
So if you remember
that your molarity is
your moles of your solute
over the total volume
of the solution, you can turn
this milliliters, assuming
a density of about 1, into
grams, grams to moles,
and you can calculate the
molarity of this solution.
You're then going to take this
30% hydrogen peroxide that we
give you, and dilute it 13.3
milliliters to 100 milliliters.
So then you can do
another dilution equation
to figure out your final
concentration of your hydrogen
peroxide that you're going
to be using in the lab.
So that's a first step.
And then I'm going
to kind of rearrange
a couple of these
other steps, just
because it'll make this a
little bit easier to go through.
But the first thing
that we're going to do
is the easy part, which is get
your rate of oxygen formation
in kilopascals per second.
And that we're just
going to read straight
from the slope of the graph.
So that's pretty easy.
So we'll have our rate
of oxygen formation
in kilopascals per second.
Great.
So now we want to take
a look at our rate law.
And we have our rate
of oxygen formation,
but what's in our rate law?
Hydrogen peroxide.
So we need to find a way to
go from oxygen and kilopascals
per second to moles per
liter per second of hydrogen
peroxide.
So the first way that
we're going to do that
is to go from kilopascals
per second here to molarity
of oxygen. And we can do that
using our gas constant here.
So if you divide by
the gas constant,
multiply by 1 over 8.314 moles,
liters times kilopascals,
we can cancel out
our kilopascals.
And we'll have moles per
liter, which is good,
but then we still
have this K, which
is our temperature
in Kelvin, so we also
have to divide by our
temperature in Kelvin.
And this will get us
our rate of oxygen
in moles per liter per
second, which is pretty good.
We're close.
But we still need to get from
oxygen to hydrogen peroxide.
So how can we get from
oxygen to hydrogen peroxide
using this information?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SARAH HEWETT: It would be--
so the ratio is 2:1, right.
So there's two
hydrogen peroxides
in this reaction for
every one oxygen.
But these coefficients
are in moles.
And this is in moles per liter.
So we need to figure out how
many moles of oxygen we have
before we can use our
stoichiometry ratio here.
So how are we going to figure
out how many moles of oxygen
we have?
We need to know what our
volume of oxygen was.
And for that we can go
to our pressure tube.
So you'll have some of this is
going to be your solution down
here, so that'll be liquid.
And then we need to calculate
the volume of the gas
above our reaction,
which is where
oxygen is going to be formed.
So we'll need to know
the volume of this,
and the volume of
the pressure tube.
And the volume of the pressure
tube has already been measured,
and we'll give that to you.
And you guys are
going to measure
in the lab what the volume
of your reaction vessel is.
You're going to fill
this thing with water,
weigh it, then weigh
it empty, and then you
can calculate by difference
in the density of water
what your volume of
your whole tube is.
And then you know your reaction
volume is 25 milliliters,
so you can subtract those and
get the volume of the gas.
So if we know
these two together,
you'll get the volume of
the gas above your reaction.
So if we have our rate of oxygen
formation in moles per liter
per second, we can
multiply that by our volume
that we calculate,
so liters of oxygen.
And then we have our rate in
moles of oxygen per second.
And now we can use
our stoichiometry,
because we have it in moles, so
we can take our rate in moles
per second, and then we know
that it is 1 mole of oxygen
for 2 moles H2O2.
Then we get our rate
H2O2 in moles per second.
And what are the units
of rate that we want?
Moles per liter per second.
So we have it in
miles per second.
We're so close.
Then we just need to divide
by the liters of our reaction,
which if you go back a couple
of slides, is 25 milliliters,
so all of our reaction
volumes are 25 milliliters.
So if you convert that
to liters, divide by 0.25
liters, and then we
will have our rate
in moles per liter per
second, which is what we want.
Now this still
doesn't get us to a,
but we can rearrange
this equation
by taking the natural
log of both sides.
So if you have the
natural log of the rate
equals the natural
log of K plus,
then the A comes down,
a times the natural log
of your hydrogen peroxide
concentration, then--
we've just figured this
out from all of that math.
We know this concentration.
And this is going to
be our y-intercept.
So if we have y
equals b plus mx,
if we make a graph
of the hydrogen--
or the natural log of the
peroxide concentration
and the natural log of
the rate, then our slope
is going to be our order.
Hopefully, we haven't lost you.
So the way that you're going to
treat all this data is you can,
instead of having to
do this calculation out
for every single trial, you
can make a giant spreadsheet.
And in the lab manual,
it tells you what data
we want you to collect.
And this is all of it here.
And then you can make
a spreadsheet that
does all of the calculations
for you, that gets you down
to the natural log of
rate, and the natural log
of hydrogen peroxide.
So this is an example
of a pretty good way
to present your data.
And I know it's kind of hard to
see on the printed out slides,
but these will be on Stellar
if you want to look at them.
And then your graph will
look something like this.
And you'll have a straight line.
And so from that
straight line, you
can figure out what your
order of your reaction
is based on your slope.
So that was a lot.
So once we have that
done on day one,
then, if you remember our
second goal for the lab,
it was to figure
out the activation
energy of the reaction.
And so the way that
we're going to do
that is to use the
Arrhenius equation,
and that says that
the rate constant is
equal to A, which is this
collision frequency factor,
times e to the negative
activation energy over RT.
And if we remember the things
that can change the rate,
we can change the
concentration and that'll
affect the rate, and
also the temperature.
So if we do our reaction
at different temperatures,
then we can determine
our activation energy.
So what you're going
to do is you're
going to pick one of
the trials from day one.
Usually people pick the middle
one because this is easy.
It's just 1 milliliter,
no decimals.
Just easy to measure and
it's right in the middle.
You'll pick one and you'll hold
the concentration of peroxide
constant, and then we
will vary the temperature.
So you'll do seven runs
at varying temperatures.
So you'll pick a temperature
in each of these ranges
and you will measure the rate.
Again, you'll get the
same graph, the measure
the rate of oxygen per second.
And then you can do
all of this same math
to get your information in
concentration of peroxide
to go from oxygen to
peroxide, because that's
what we care about.
The keys to success
for this reaction
are to wait for the
peroxide and the buffer
to reach the correct temperature
before you add the enzyme.
So when you have your
reaction here in this tube,
you'll put it in your
water bath and then
you want to give
it a few minutes
to stir and come to equilibrium
at the right temperature,
because it'll all be
at room temperature.
And then if you're trying to do
your reaction at 0 degrees or 5
degrees, your reaction part
won't actually be at 5 degrees
even if your water bath is.
So give it a few
minutes to equilibrate
before you take
your measurements
and before you
inject your enzyme.
Another key to
success is to start
at the hottest temperature
and then add ice to cool it.
It's easier to
control the cooling
than it is to control the
heating with these hot plates.
The hot plates tend
to get really excited
and then they'll
heat your solution up
way above what it needs to, and
then it won't be able to cool.
So if you start at your hottest
temperature and then add ice,
you'll be able to slowly
lower the temperature
and do it in a more
controlled fashion.
The other important
thing about this reaction
for day one and two, and I'm
sure your TAs will emphasize
this when they tell you in
lab and you guys have a chance
to have this in front of you,
is to do everything really
quickly.
So the reaction starts as
soon as you add the enzyme.
So you'll have
your micropipette,
you'll stick it
right in that hole,
add the enzyme
really fast, and then
you want to attach
your pressure tube
and then hit go on your computer
to start collecting the data.
And that all has to happen
in like, a second so
that you don't miss that
beginning of your data
collection.
So those are some
important things.
If we talk about the data
analysis for this reaction,
it's kind of similar
to the other one.
So you'll calculate the
concentration of peroxide,
you'll calculate the volume
of air above your reaction.
You'll have the initial
rate of oxygen formation
in kilopascals per second.
Then you can get the initial
rate of oxygen formation
in molarity per second
and moles per second.
Then you can change your
rate of oxygen formation
to the rate of peroxide
decomposition, same math.
And then using the rate law
that you determined on day one,
you're going to calculate
the rate constant.
So if we have our rate,
our general rate law,
we'll measure this in the lab or
we'll calculate this, I guess.
We will know this from day one.
So you'll plug in
the value that you
get from your first set of
calculations right there.
And then we measure
this in the lab
or we can
calculate/measure this.
So we can calculate
our rate constant,
which is, if you just
rearrange this, it'll be k--
so that's not so bad.
And then in order to get our
activation energy out of this,
we are again going to take
the natural log of both sides.
I think that I did
that out correctly.
No plus sign here.
All right, so this is your
linear form of this equation.
So we have, again,
y equals b m and x.
So if we do our reaction
at different temperatures,
then we will know the
temperature of our reaction.
And then we will get k from
our rate constant from our rate
law, and you'll calculate
that for each of your trials,
as well, based on the rate.
And then our slope is going
to be the activation energy
over the ideal gas constant.
So we can get the
activation energy
from the slope of
a graph of 1 over t
times the natural log of k
versus the natural log of k.
And then you can also get your
collision frequency factor,
this A term, from
your y-intercept,
so you'll also be able
to determine that.
Then you'll use
your Linus program
to get the errors in
all of these things,
and that is essentially day
one and day two of the lab.
Do you guys have any
questions about that?
There's a lot of math.
So again, there's
another data chart
that you can make for
day two of the lab that
has all of the information
that you're going
to need for these calculations.
And then this is hopefully
what your graph will look like.
It should be linear
with a negative slope,
and then the negative
will get taken
care of with that negative
sign in the equation.
AUDIENCE: This will
be posted on Stellar?
SARAH HEWETT: Yes.
Yeah, all of the slides
will be posted on Stellar
so you can see it
in a larger form,
because I know they didn't
print out super well.
OK.
So now we can take a
look at the reaction
that you're going to do in
a slightly different form.
And you may have
seen this before,
but we're going to do it anyway.
So hydrogen peroxide, you
may have some at your house.
They sell it in a drugstore.
It's like, 3% so it's not
as concentrated as the stuff
that we're going to
be using in the lab.
But nonetheless,
hydrogen peroxide
is a thing that you can buy.
And it naturally
decomposes over time,
so this reaction is
always happening.
If you have a bottle
of hydrogen peroxide,
usually the caps are vented
because if you seal it
for too long, you'll build
up pressure of oxygen
and that's a problem.
The stuff that we have
in the lab is 30%,
so that's definitely vented, and
we store it in the refrigerator
so that we slow
down the reaction
and keep our product for longer.
So it is always happening
and you can speed it up
in a number of ways.
So one of the ways is obviously
using enzymes, catalase.
That'll speed up the reaction.
But there are other catalysts
that you can use, as well.
So have you guys seen the
elephant toothpaste reaction
before?
Yes.
Do you guys know
what the catalyst
is that we use for this?
There's a few you can use,
but does anyone remember?
So we're going to react
hydrogen peroxide with potassium
iodide in this case.
And you can use a
couple different ones,
like manganese dioxide,
I believe, works.
You can use different
iodide salts,
but potassium iodide is
the one that I have today.
And we're going to do a
little bit of an experiment.
So we said that concentration
effects rate, right?
So we will try
our first reaction
with some hydrogen peroxide.
And I'm going to pour out
about 10 milliliters of this
and then dilute it so that our
new concentration is about 7%.
Yeah, that's right.
So pour that in there.
And then we want to use a
potassium iodide solution.
So we can pour some
of this in here.
And then we have
the oxygen bubbles,
and who did the catalase
reaction yesterday in lab?
Anybody who's here?
So what did you guys see
when you added the enzyme
to your peroxide in the tube?
Bubbles, good.
But it didn't foam up, right?
Because they just popped
and formed oxygen.
So the way that we can get this
to foam is by adding some soap.
This is just powdered soap.
And we can add a couple
of scoops of that.
And now hopefully,
if all goes well,
when I add these together,
we will see the decomposition
of hydrogen peroxide.
I can probably hold it up so
you can see what's happening.
So what's happening in there?
It's bubbling, good.
Excellent.
So what are the bubbles?
Oxygen. All right, so
it's taking its time.
So while that is going,
we can set up another one.
And this time, we won't
dilute the hydrogen peroxide,
so we'll just use 40 milliliters
of hydrogen peroxide.
Need our soap.
Yeah.
Yeah, so it looks
like toothpaste maybe.
Toothpaste that an
elephant would use, yeah.
What?
Elephant toothpaste.
Yeah.
I also, in the course of
doing some research for this,
found that some people call
it old foamy, like a guyser.
So you may have heard
it by that name.
All right, and then
we add the same amount
of potassium iodide.
Hopefully I measured
this out properly.
So if that was 7%
hydrogen peroxide,
what do we think is going
to happen if we use 30%?
Faster.
Let's find out.
So can you see the
steam coming off of it?
Yeah, so what does that
mean about the reaction?
It's exothermic.
Yeah, it's very hot.
If you were to come up here and
touch this, it is quite warm.
But yeah, so that
went faster, right?
So we can do a
little bit of math
about how much faster the
potassium iodide makes
the reaction go than just what
would happen in your bottle
at home.
And so our activation energy of
hydrogen peroxide decomposition
that is uncatalyzed,
just happens in nature,
is 75 kilojoules per mole.
So if we use our
Arrhenius equation,
then we can plug in 75
kilojoules or 75,000 joules
to match our or
gas constant units.
And then the activation
energy of the decomposition
as catalyzed by
potassium iodide is
about 56 kilojoules per
mole, so it lowers it,
makes the reaction go faster.
If you do this math out--
I don't want to get my
numbers wrong here--
it is about 2,500 times
faster or 2,400 times faster
than what would
happen in nature.
Now, if we talk about
catalase, and you guys
will calculate the
actual activation
energy of the
catalase-catalyzed reaction,
I will start and tell you that
it is less than 10 kilojoules
per mole.
So that is a pretty
significant change, right?
Going from 75 kilojoules
per mole down to 10 or less.
That's a lot.
So if you do this math out,
where you go from 75,000 joules
to 10,000 joules, does
anyone have any guesses
as to how much faster
the catalase is
than just normal decomposition?
A lot.
So that's a lot faster.
So you can be
thinking about that
when you are thinking
about what happens
in the cells of your body
because you are forming
these superoxide radicals
and hydrogen peroxide
all the time in your cells.
And this reaction is happening
on this scale, or the reaction
that you just saw is happening
this many times faster
in your body, and you will see
it happen also in your flask.
So any questions, thoughts?
No?
All right, well, thank you guys.
You can head to lab.